All right.
This is super interesting and it's really
just a pleasure to watch one of the most prominent
people who plans to formally object.
Sir, I object to the counting of the electoral
votes.
Tomorrow is Republican Senator Josh Hawley,
because Josh Holley was, I guess because he
was the first senator to announce he would
object, he's received more attention than
some other senators who jumped on the bandwagon
after the fact.
And Josh Hawley went on Fox News yesterday.
Good for him.
And Bret Bair actually pushed back on the
nonsense that Josh Hawley was touting.
And Josh Hawley became visibly uncomfortable.
He had that look on his face that Tucker Carlson
is known for, where it's sort of like a dog
hearing your voice out of the answering machine
and kind of like a confusion.
And when Bret Bair starts pushing back on
Josh Hawley, Josh Hawley gets that look.
Here is Bret Bair, starting with what exactly
is the point of you objecting tomorrow or,
you know, Wednesday?
What are you what is the goal of that?
Take a listen.
So this is why it didn't take up that.
That case, either they did not take up the
case to the Supreme Court.
We've seen courts across the country deal
not only with not the standing of different
cases, but also the evidence and some of them
trumped Trump judges.
I just want to pin you down on on what you're
trying to do.
You know, are you trying to say that as of
January 20th that President Trump will be
president?
Well, that depends on what happens on Wednesday.
I mean, this is why we have the debate.
No, this is what I mean by the Constitution.
Say they certify the election.
They did certify it by the Constitution.
Congress doesn't have the right to overturn
the certification, at least as most experts
read it.
So Bret Bair is completely correct.
Tomorrow's electoral vote count is ceremonial.
Mike Pence's role is perfunctory.
The states have already certified their electoral
votes.
That's the legally binding piece.
State certification tomorrow is really ceremonial.
And this is where Josh Holly starts to get
a sourpuss look on his face like he bit into
a lemon and just start to tell some lies.
Well, Congress is is directed under the 12th
Amendment to count the electoral votes, there's
a statute that dates back to the nineteen
to the eighteen hundreds, rather, 19th century
that says that there is a right to object,
there's a right to be heard.
And there's also a certification.
Right.
That's from 1876, Senator.
And it's it's the the Tilden Hayes race in
which there were three states that did not
certify their their electors.
So Congress was left to come up with the system,
this commission that eventually got to negotiate
a grand bargain.
But now all of the states have certified their
elections as of December 14th.
So it doesn't, by constitutional ways, open
a door to Congress to overturn that, does
it?
When Brett Beyer knows the example that Holly
is referring to, Holly realizes, oh, no, this
is not going to go that well.
And Brett Beyer is completely correct.
What Josh Holly is referring to is a mechanism
that's really in place for when some states
have not certified the electoral vote.
That's not the case this year.
Every state on between December 14th.
Can you believe it's been a month since that
it feels like days on December 14th, every
state certified the electoral vote.
And then listen to Josh Holley's answer.
Well, no, I'm talking about the statute.
There's a statute that says that governs what
Congress does on January the 6th, and it says
that we have a vote of certification and that
we have to we have the opportunity to debate
the results, to certify the results.
We count them and then we certify.
And my point is, this is my only opportunity
during this process to raise an objection
and to be heard.
I don't have standing to file lawsuits.
I'm not a prosecutor anymore.
I used to be, but I'm not anymore.
I can't investigate claims of voter fraud
on my own.
But I do have a responsibility in this joint
session of Congress to either say, I've got
no problem with it or I do have a problem
with it and my constituents accept.
But don't you dare to say to your constituents,
don't you have a responsibility to tell them
that it's not going to be President Trump
as of January 21st as well?
What we're so there, Josh, Holly kind of admits
the truth, which is this is all I can do,
and that's what this is all about.
What is there that anyone can do, given that
Joe Biden won and all they can do is virtue
signal to Donald Trump?
They are trying that they are trying.
So Holly has definitely he he seemed to be
expecting more of a fawning softball interview
from Bret Bair.
Much of the Fox News audience is furious with
Bret Bair for pointing out that Josh Holley
is lying to them.
After all, you would think that an audience
would want to know if an elected official
is lying to them.
But no, the Fox audience is mad that Bret
Baier exposed Josh Holly's lies.
But Holly's just squirming and it's fantastic
and it will all be over very soon.
I'm still receiving and we even got some paid
super chats during yesterday's Trump rally
livestream.
I'm still getting messages from people saying
totally seriously, David, don't you realize
that by Thursday, Trump will be the official
winner and Biden is going to be in handcuffs?
Well, listen, I don't even have to argue we're
down to the last 48 hours.
Let's wait and see and we will see very soon.
Let me know what you expect tomorrow in Washington,
D.C.
Let me know via Twitter where you can find
me at the
Pakman
The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman
dot com.